nos piden que identifiquemos el
porcentaje cantidad y base en este
problema y nos preguntan 150 es 25% de
qué número no nos piden que lo
resolvamos pero estoy tentado a hacerlo
así que lo que va a ser primero resolver
este problema el cual ni siquiera nos
están preguntando así que lo primero es
resolver este problema y luego podemos
pensar acerca del porcentaje cantidad y
base que son simplemente términos
simples definiciones lo importante es
ser capaz de resolver un problema como
este y nos dicen 150 150 es 25 por
ciento de que el número otra manera de
ver esto es 150 es 25 por ciento de
algún número digamos entonces que sea x
igual al número el número
del cual 150 es 25 por ciento de acuerdo
eso es lo que tenemos que calcular 150
es 25 por ciento de qué número es el
número es x entonces que tenemos si
tenemos x y tomamos el 25% el 25 por
ciento de x eso es como si multiplicamos
esta x por 25 % 25% de x y esto es
exactamente igual si lo vemos en
notación decimal a que lo pongamos como
0.25 por x ambas expresiones son
idénticas si tienes un número le tomas
el 25% es decir lo multiplicas por punto
25 esto va a ser exactamente igual a 150
esto es igual a 150 150 es 25% de este
número y entonces despejamos la equis
así que empecemos desde aquí sí tenemos
déjame escribirlo por separado para que
entiendas lo que estamos haciendo 0.25
por un número
al 150 ahora tenemos dos maneras de
hacer esto podemos dividir ambos lados
de la ecuación por 0.25 o si reconocemos
que cuatro cuartos hacen un dólar
podemos considerar multiplicar ambos
lados de la ecuación por cual de
cualquier las dos maneras sale que va a
ser la primera porque es el método como
normalmente resolvemos ecuaciones como
esta dividamos entonces el lado
izquierdo entre 0.25 y el lado derecho
también lo dividimos entre 0.25 esto va
a ser equis y el lado derecho va a ser
150 entre 0.25 es una buena práctica
dividida entre un número decimal
así es que hagámoslo así así que
queremos calcular cuánto es 150 dividido
entre 0.25 ya hemos hecho esto antes
cuando divides en tu número decimal lo
que se hace es convertir el número
decimal en un número entero y en este
caso lo podemos hacer moviendo el punto
decimal dos lugares a la derecha pero si
haces eso para el denominador también
hay que hacerlo para el numerador este
150 lo puedes ver como 150.00
entonces si multiplicas 25% corremos el
punto decimal dos lugares a la derecha
lo mismo hacemos para 150 corremos el
punto decimal dos lugares a la derecha y
obtenemos 15.000 así movemos el punto
decimal tenemos entonces que dividir 150
entre 0.25
es lo mismo que dividir 15000 entre 25
hagamos esto rápidamente entonces
cuántas veces cada 25 en 150 no cabe en
uno tampoco caben 15 y en 150 cabe
sabemos que cabe 4 vez en 100 así es que
en 150 cabe 6 veces
ahora seis por punto 25 de hecho es 6
por 25 aquí tenemos ya el punto decimal
lo corrimos hacia allá 6 por 25 es 150
restamos 150 menos 150 y 0 bajamos este
0 0 entre 25 nos da 0 0 por 25 es cero
0 - 0 0 bajamos este otro cero otra vez
0 entre 25 300 por 2500 menos 20 así 150
0.25 es igual a 600 y lo podrías haber
hecho mentalmente cuando estabas en esta
parte de la ecuación 0.25 por equis
igual a 150 si multiplicamos por 4
tenemos 4 por punto 25 4 por un cuarto
es igual a 1 nos queda x del lado
izquierdo y del lado derecho sería 4 por
150 es igual a 600 de cualquier las dos
maneras es correcto y esto hace sentido
si 150 es 25% de algún número eso
significa que 150 debe ser la cuarta
parte de dicho número debe ser mucho
menor que dicho número 150 es un cuarto
de 600 contestemos entonces la pregunta
identifica el porcentaje bueno parece
que el porcentaje es 25% 25% es el
porcentaje la cantidad y la base
basándose en como lo están planteando yo
supongo que la cantidad significa cuando
tú tomas el 25% de la base así que la
cantidad como yo lo entiendo es la
cantidad va a ser igual
la cantidad va a ser igual al porcentaje
x déjame ponerlo en verde porcentaje
multiplicado por la base así la base es
el número del cual estás tomando el
porcentaje y la cantidad es el valor de
ese porcentaje
entonces ya vimos que el porcentaje lo
tenemos aquí el porcentaje es 25% es el
porcentaje el número del cual obtuvimos
el 25%
ese número es este valor de x ese número
es el valor de xy corresponde a la base
cuyo valor es 600 ese lo calculamos y la
cantidad la cantidad es 150
eso también lo calculamos 150 es la
cantidad es 25 por ciento de la base de
600 lo importante aquí es como
resolvimos el problema no las palabras
en sí eso como tú bien sabes son en
realidad meras definiciones